bonjour merci d'être avec nous comment
est ce que vous avez accueilli cette
mise en examen
alors qu'au départ on est on était ravi
que ce soit les enfants tombent et la
mise en examen il nous manque deux quand
même qu'ils ont été mis un conte était
cité à témoins ont ni sur celle là dans
la fille
la policière qui étaient mises en
situation de témoins comprends pas qu'on
prend pas parce que pour moi il ya non
assistance à personne en danger
en plus de l'agression et de la mise à
mort qu'on a effectués sur mon fils
donc je comprends pas ce sujet et puis
ils ont toujours pas été mise à pied
monsieur castaner le ministre castaner
avait promis que aussitôt qu'il y avait
un coeur qui avait une mise en examen il
serait aujourd'hui un changement de
ministre alors on doit être patient mais
je pense que c'est quand même honteux ce
qui se passe que les relais soit il pas
fait systématiquement et qu'on les aime
pas mais on n'en avait pas fait de mise
à pied systématique c'est c'est
scandaleux de laisser des meurtriers
comme ça dans la rue au gré est pour
l'instant du début de la faire on était
dans un tissu de mensonges fait par la
police et aujourd'hui ça continue alors
on espère que ce nouveau ministre aura
plus de poids n'y aura plus de deux
sujets sera moins menteur que monsieur
castaner le ministre elle rend comprends
votre mécontentement contre à la gestion
de cette enquête en cours qu'est ce que
vous attendez aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on
attend que les quatre sur les rangs dans
la même circonstance dans les mêmes
circonstances
dans un premier temps qu'ils soient ils
et quatre sur une mise à pied on
comprend pas on y en avait
on nous a dit quand il y avait enlevé le
port d'armes pour un des quatre il a pu
par dame et peut continuer à travailler
c'est quoi c'est un scandale c'est c'est
comique cette histoire c'est une
histoire comique on sait pas comment
faire je te passe la balle balle au
centre
c'est quoi ces sagas sainghin que c'est
quoi cette je dirais pas cette justice
parce que la justice pour l'instant fait
son travail mais derrière le ministère
ne fait pas son travail le ministère jeu
par jeu par le mystère de la police qui
a le parfum à prendre ça un peu à la
légère france et pourtant comme d'autres
à faudra vous qui vous a touché de près
elle ce drame qui vous a touché de près
a conduit à faire bouger les lignes
concernant les pratiques de maintien de
l'ordre est ce que vous avez le
sentiment que malgré tout il ya une
prise de conscience quant à cette
pratique à ses méthodes
bah oui parce que à chaque fois à chaque
fois qu'on arrive au bout il ya eu
meurtre
on prend la sphère traoré on prend
toutes les affaires ça se termine
toujours pareil plaquage ventrale morts
à l'aller les raisons les causes
il n'y a pas une fois qu'ils ont arrêté
quelqu'un avec une ceinture d'explosifs
avec des arbres ou machin c'est toujours
des gens pour un contrôle d'identité
suspect ou pas suspects contre une
identité qui se termine par un drame
cédric souvient est un travailleur ça se
termine par un drame
il meurt il meurt sur le pavé donc vous
comprenez que aujourd'hui on peut pas
accepter des ddd des trucs aussi simple
aussi banal que ça c'est pas possible
moi je suis pas d'accord sur l'heure sur
la façon vous tournés aujourd'hui vers
le nouveau ministre de l'intérieur
qu'est ce que vous lui demandez darmanin
m'sieurs-dames ministre darmana je lui
demande d'être actif et d'être surtout
réactif et ds bouger on peut pas faire
ça on peut pas
rester comme ça inactifs pas il faut
qu'il intervienne qui prennent position
et qui bougent parce qu'il faut qu'ils
soient y sévères qu'ils fassent
comprendre que dans la police il ya des
très bons policiers qu'à police elle ne
s'est pas cassé pas y'a pas de
pourcentage de mauvaises bon il ya de
très bons policiers on n'en doute pas où
on est on sait pertinemment que la
police s'est passé c'est pas là la
représentation de ces 4 à 5 5 ont conçu
un homme est pareil pour la famille
traoré paris pour toutes les familles y
a pas c'est pas il n'y a pas que des
assassins dans la police et des gens qui
font leur métier difficilement avec un
manque de moyens on est conscient tout
ça
la famille shaw vient la seule chose
qu'on vous demande monsieur darmanin
c'est d'appliquer les règles et d'api
d'arrêter le mensonge parce que depuis
le 3 janvier 2020 à 10h30 le mensonge a
démarré et aujourd'hui continue donc
faut arrêter
j'espère que ce nouveau ministre sera un
homme un vrai homme et qui le sera il
sera se faire reconnaître par les
administrations par les syndicats et qui
sera sans poser et pas faire du bla bla
bla bla parce qu'à chaque fois je
regarderai à chaque fois je rebondirai
mois représentant de la famille avec
toute la famille on rebondira on né sera
pas impuni impunie la mort de mon fils
merci c'est clair et net je laisserai
pas impuni me suis dharmanand pas
messieurs dames 1 merci christian
olszowiak je rappelle que vous n'êtes
pas le père de cédric jovial a disparu
en janvier